sergio coronado écologiste tête de liste
à l'élection municipale a bondi avec le
soutien de la france insoumis c'est
notre invité politique ce soir bonsoir
bonsoir faire coronado merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur ft france avant de
décrypter l'actualité notamment
françaises
évidemment tu as été sociale chargée on
en parlera cette visite hier on l'a vu
des manuels mais kron dans la vieille
ville de jérusalem et son altercation
vous aussi vous dénoncez à un coude
comme j'avais fait également un tweet
qui mettait en exergue en fait la
similitude avec ce qui s'était passé il
ya plusieurs années
al'approche de la basilique sainte anne
à jérusalem qui est un territoire
français là en l'occurrence
puisque on avait l'impression
effectivement que presque mot à mot le
président macron voulait emprunter les
pas de jacques chirac
la différence est que jacques chirac
avait une politique qui lui permettait
en fait d'apparaître comme quelqu'un qui
se faisait respecter notamment par les
services de sécurité d'israël et à
l'époque ce qui n'est loin de là le cas
des prisons macron dont on voit de plus
en plus l'atlantisme le suivisme à
l'égard de la politique nord-américaine
et donc je crois en effet que c'est un
coup de com ça a été relevé par
plusieurs observateurs et pas les plus
hostiles au président de la république
voilà qui résume bien en fait la
politique internationale des manuels
macro alors justement sur l'anti
sémitisme 1 et c'est beaucoup et exprimé
également cet anniversaire a été
l'occasion d'évoquer l'augmentation des
actes antisémites en france comment vous
avez perçu le discours du président de
la république qui ont ce n'est pas
nouveau il ya une loi qui sur ce point
associés l'antisionisme à
l'antisémitisme n'est pas une loi en
fait il s'agit d'une résolution qui
n'est pas contraignant qu'il a
patiemment valeur ni les slides unis
juridique
je crois qu'il ya une très grande
confusion d'ailleurs il y avait eu un
appel l'intellectuel juif et notamment
de grands chercheurs professeurs
écrivains israéliens qui dénonçait la
confusion qu'il y aurait à présenter en
fait toute critique de la politique
gouvernementale israélienne comme une
forme d'antisémitisme je crois que
l'antisémitisme est un fléau qu'il faut
le combattre que nous disposons en
france notamment d'un arsenal juridique
suffisamment complet et qu'il ne me
paraît pas sage il ne me paraît pas
souhaitable de faire d'un débat
politique c'est à dire de l'appréciation
de la politique israélienne
un combat ou contre l'antisémitisme ou
utiliser cette critique là comme si
c'était en fait une expression de
l'antisémitisme je crois que ce sont
deux choses distinctes
et quand on joue la confusion on
affaiblit en fait la lutte nécessaire
indispensable contre l'antisémitisme
justement vous l'avez vu ces
augmentations d'actes antisémites
comment vous l'expliquez vous et si vous
étiez au pouvoir comment voulu terrier
contre ce fléau en france
d'abord on est un dispositif législatif
et juridique qui permet en fait de
poursuivre de condamner la sienne il y a
également en fait un travail pédagogique
nécessaire et je crois qu'il y ait à la
fois une augmentation des actes
antisémites médiane on l'a noté
également dans l'actualité
l'augmentation des actes racistes en
général des violences à l'égard des
minorités des personnes lgbt
je crois que cela fait partie d'une des
grandes missions de l'éducation
nationale de construire en fait la
conscience la citoyenneté de lutter
contre les discriminations et le racisme
et ensuite évidemment une attention
particulière moi je le vis comme
candidat aujourd'hui à l'élection miss
elle a bondi contre ces formes de
dérapage ses formes de violence qui
enfreignent en fait la capacité que nous
avons à vivre ensemble à vivre en commun
la loi via par exemple efficace pour
vous est ce qu'elle peut contribuer à
limiter les propos haineux sur internet
et prendre le problème du bon goût quand
je m'attarde sur le texte proposé par
les parlementaires dont madame attias
avocate par ailleurs rapporteur je me
dis que l'enfer est pavé de bonnes
intentions
encore une fois la plupart des
spécialistes les meilleurs connaisseurs
du domaine en fait du numérique sont
vent debout contre ce texte de loi vous
avez lu les dernières déclarations du
syndicat des avocats du conseil national
du numérique de la quadrature du cercle
de la ligue des droits de l'homme
il y à une évolution inquiétante depuis
des décennies dans notre pays c'est
l'effacement en fait du judiciaire dans
ces procédures le juge est le seul et
l'unique garant de nos libertés
je fait de décider de déléguer à des
plateformes privées en fait la capacité
de réguler et donc de censurer mais
paraître un très grand risque
et puis une inquiétude également ses je
ne sais pas ce qui est défini sous le
vocable de haine et c'est très compliqué
d'ailleurs le texte de loi dans son
introduction non-dits pains seulement
d'après une étude qui a été publiée par
le sénat il ya eu 160 mille signalement
sur la plateforme
pharos en 2018 et moins de quatorze
mille en fait de ces signalements
pouvaient être rattachées à des propos
de haine ou à des propos de
discrimination donc je crois que
appréhender la globalité de ce problème
peut paraître une position juste en
revanche les propositions qui sont
aujourd'hui portés par ce texte de loi
vise à généraliser une forme de censure
privé et je crois que c'est très
inquiétant je rappelle par ailleurs
qu'il a été introduit à la demande du
gouvernement un amendement
particulièrement inquiétant sur demande
de la police
il y aurait retrait sous les 24 heures
dans les 24 heures en fait tout tout
publication pose en difficulté
qu'en serait-il si cette loi avait été
adopté il ya plusieurs années concernant
par exemple les violences policières qui
ont été d'abord et vous le savez très
bien parce que vous avez été un des
seuls médias a porté la faire devant le
public constructive des violences
policières qui ont d'abord été montré
sur les réseaux sociaux qui ont fait des
l'objet de signalement et notamment d'un
journaliste bien connu désormais david
dufresne
si la police avait eu cette capacité
finalement à mettre en exergue à
dénoncer à s'opposer à leur diffusion
sous couvert de propos de haine à
l'égard des forces de l'ordre
moi je suis très inquiet en fait qu'on
délègue à des intérêts privés des
plateformes privées la régulation d'un
espace de liberté d'expression et que
par ailleurs la place du juge dans ces
questions qui me paraissent prioritaires
compte à nos libertés soit à chaque fois
marginalisée
l'actualité c'est aussi évidemment
toujours projet de réforme des retraites
avec une nouvelle grande journée de
mobilisation demain alors que dans le
même temps le projet présenté en conseil
des ministres vous pensez que ça va
encore changer quelque chose de se
mobiliser le gouvernement l'air
déterminé à aller jusqu'au bout
le gouvernement a l'air évidemment
déterminé depuis le départ d'ailleurs on
a deux ans
de négociation factice a pour dire les
choses telles qu'elles ont été vécus par
les principaux acteurs et notamment du
monde syndical
je constate qu'il ya une forme de
radicalité d' aveuglement de refus en
fait de ouvrir un dialogue et de faire
jouer la démocratie sociale dans ce pays
de la part du gouvernement
ce que je constate aussi c'est que la
détermination elle n'est pas simplement
du côté du gouvernement elle est aussi
du côté de celles et de ceux qui
majoritairement aujourd'hui dans le pays
s'opposent à ce projet de réforme qui a
introduit en fait un système à points
qui met fin aux régimes paritaires tel
que nous le connaissons sous prétexte de
lutter contre les régimes spéciaux alors
qu'ils en créent de nombreux autres ce
que l'on sait et moi je suis bien placé
pour le savoir d'abord que j'y suis né
dans ce pays de le chili et j'étais
parlementaire des français et avionique
l'at-il les pays qui ont mis en place ce
type de réforme connaissent des
situations similaires c'est à dire un
appauvrissement général des pensions à
un appauvrissement général de des
retraités conteuse comment on stoppe le
gouvernement parce que l'équation et
devient extrêmement compliqué la grande
majorité des français 61% veulent le
retrait de ce projet dans le même temps
un forum à la mode 56% d'entre eux
demandent la fin de la grève certains
syndicats aujourd'hui cfe cgc demande
une pause même si vous demandent
toujours le retrait mais une pause dans
la mobilisation donc c'est quand vous
lisez les enquêtes la grèce et c'est un
inconvénient c'est sa force
et depuis le double droit par exemple en
région parisienne les gens en ont pâti
on en fait les romances mobiliser ses
difficultés
cogeco verbale c'est que ce mouvement
est assez extraordinaire vous le voyez
dans les images que vous montrez en ce
moment c'est qu'il fait preuve d'une
très grande créativité et que même si on
peut juger en effet que la grève est un
moyen mobilisation qui peut présenter
des problèmes parce que ça peut
souhaiter de la désaffection des gens
qui peuvent en raison des difficultés
rencontrées quotidiennement sont
éloignés
diminuer leurs encouragements ou leur
soutien à nos protestations
ce que je constate moi c'est que ce
mouvement est capable de nouvelles
formes d'action
on voit des retraites aux flambeaux on
voit les avocats par exemple les
danseurs de l'opéra ballet de l'opéra de
paris qui ont offert des spectacles
le choeur de radio france les orchestres
philharmoniques je crois qu'on avait
rarement vu depuis fort longtemps dans
ce pays en france une telle créativité
dans la mobilisation
ce qui veut dire en fait c'est que ce
mouvement même s'il connaît des
difficultés parce que tenir une grève de
plus de 40 jours c'est extrêmement
difficile les gens le paye
financièrement plein de secteurs qui
joue un rôle moins clé en fait dans
l'appareil productif dans le déplacement
de nos concitoyens se mobilisent et se
mobilisent avec leurs armes propres
on le voit quotidiennement dans les
médias sur les réseaux sociaux etc la
preuve en fait que la détermination ne
faiblit pas et que le mouvement
s'élargit
merci beaucoup en tout cas sergio
coronado je rappelle que vous êtes
candidat à bondy on aura l'occasion
certainement parler des des municipales
partielles le ton est un peu fi des très
rapidement voilà candidat a bondi pour
les municipales merci à vous d'en